[Music]
in Reverse twinky news hmm permitted by
man in a horse body a Hawaiian Congress
man received backlash after stating that
he's an Asian trapped in a white body oh
my god
it's gonna white guy that thinks he's
Asian yeah that's dope
what is that that's a that's a that's an
egg it's a reverse Twitter so where have
you been today we went with reverse
Twinkie okay yeah so there's egg
it's an egg I think that's all got haole
syndrome yeah how many syndrome from
I've heard a lot of them more Hawaiian
are places because they they like beef
with the white people so much that I
[ __ ] how can I assimilate in this
culture it's crazy that I'm white but
I'm the minority here well I think yeah
that happens with wherever you are you
want to be like the majority of the
people that grew up in Hawaii yeah
that's why she married my dad was
Filipino because she looked like a local
boy yeah mm-hmm like she was just really
immersed in the Hawaiian culture which
Hawaii has a lot of Filipinos in it too
and she liked that family-oriented thing
but then I grew up in in Santa Barbara
where everyone was white and so I wanted
blonde hair I wanted to have green eyes
you know you just like walk whatever
everyone you and your mom could never
relate because she wants to be Asian and
then you honor that she would always be
like you're such beautiful tan skin and
like your your hair is so shiny and it's
not curly and I just like true cuz you
could pass for a local girl in Hawaii
yeah they always are like I'm gonna
discount I'm like oh yeah I know my mom
will get treated like the tourists and
we'd all know treated like locals no my
dad grew up in LA like I grew up in a
perception
pidgin accent she did when she lived
there yeah yeah so this is for Nikki
[Laughter]
yeah so this congressman his name is
Edie
he told attendees at this event that was
celebrating the Asian America American
and Pacific Islander members of Congress
that he is an Asian trapped in a white
body I know I know some token ass white
people that would hang out with a bunch
of Asians and I would be like yeah you
are the Asian trapped in my body like I
had a friend who majored in Asian
American Studies his like love for
Asians was just off the roof charts man
that she would sit through the roof I
got it together chain let's combine the
two together chain like Tommy [ __ ] on
the chain wax
I always Chapelle do you bill
okay Bo okay chain yeah so he was saying
cuz he's married like his wife is Asian
Japanese American horse and he was just
talking about how like the comments that
she'll say about him so then that's
that's what led to that statement is our
outrage about accepting as funny and
cute um they're just cool is all this
Rachel Dolezal [ __ ] yeah and then just
saying they were like this one tweet was
like I wonder if tilde or scarlet will
play the Asian trapped in IDI cases body
yeah and then people are like Ike that's
crazy
hey well I will see what happens when he
has kids if he shows them know love and
affection maybe people live their lives
that's funny so I guess everyone doesn't
believe in reincarnation depends on how
they said it too cuz you know how some
people be like yeah
inside I'm big
so whatever like if he's saying it as a
joke or is he like does he really
[ __ ] believe that by saying that also
that now he can speak on Asian topics
now that's there's a clear difference in
that that's not right yeah so yeah I
mean that's all the context I have
people just don't like it that he said
it um it was just like yeah why because
it sounded like he was just making a
story of like how his wife you know says
that he has a lot of like Asian traits
or whatever so he's probably like oh
yeah yeah I do feel that the thing is
because the tweet that made this whole
conversation start was by this man named
Nicholas he is a National Journal data
and visualization person and so he was
present at this event in Washington DC
so he tweeted a photo of that whole
thing and then he captioned it with
congressman Edie case who represents a
majority Asian district in Honolulu and
then the quote an Asian trapped in a
white body that's all the context that
people had and yeah yeah because if you
made good calls for that district yeah
you use agent inside yeah it's dude for
being in touch with the people around
you it's not about race I think I feel
like yeah like things like that if you
don't have the whole story to it's
difficult because in the right context
I'll be cool with them saying [ __ ] like
that cuz I've heard it before and as a
joke it's cool like if he has McDonald's
napkins in the glove compartment of his
car for spare use that's pre Asian is it
an Asian thing to always have a youth
tissue in your pocket like a tissue that
oh god he always do my dad always has a
tissue in socket and when people need a
tissue he's like I got one we're like
I'm good I don't share mine I just have
it yesterday
maybe you're a notice yeah with no
clothes Oh gross you're like an egg
burrito
you're sharing it with people no no I
just had a used one in my pocket that
was it um but yes the angry Asian man he
tweeted oh yeah what happened to him
well you still go like no Edie no Sam
you doesn't even know the contest thank
you so mad
so angry Phil get so involved like
because it's their identity like their
other identity I feel like there's an
Asian guy inside of Steve exactly so but
I guess the difference is if I say it
versus if Steve said it right right I
don't know who knows I don't even know
that fool that's what could be more
Asian than me
duffle got better Mandarin the newest
[ __ ] I know [ __ ] that's like when they
were saying that um that one actor on
crazy rich Asians wasn't great Asian
enough cuz he was like half white I
forgot what 20 balding yeah that will
grow up in Asia so you have all these
Asian Americans that were born in
America that can't even summer came to
[ __ ] speak they're like like parents
language and [ __ ] and in there telling
this guy he's not Asian enough because
he's half white there's an elitist
mentality with that too because like a
lot of Filipino even Filipino Americans
that weren't even from the Philippines
that are just here or like oh you're not
Filipino cuz you're half white like no
no you're not Filipino if you don't
point with your lips right
because of all the issue with the whole
Rachel Dolezal thing is it's just like
you can't you can't pick and choose that
because you can't pick and choose how
people perceive your ethnicity right so
like I don't I don't know if is that
extreme in Asian people in America but
like for the whole Rachel Dolezal being
is not the same history she she kind of
passes for black and she she lies that
she's black right yeah what did I'm
saying like the issue that they had what
that was kind of like you can't so
you're clearly you're white right but
you get to pick and choose your
upbringing so you didn't grow up as a
black person so you got to reap all the
benefits of being a white person and
then you choose to be black because a
better sister case yeah right so that's
that situation I'm not sure how that
applies here though maybe that's why
people could be upset it's like well
you're still a white guy people still
see you as a white kid but you're not
going through Asian people she's Rachel
Dolezal or whatever isn't hers a little
bit more extreme because she was she was
kind of wearing a costume and this guy's
like not like putting tape on his eyes
it's a little different but we should
give the whole I would feel way more
offended with the chick um then I did
with this guy yeah I'm not offended I'm
just saying like I guess like if you
want to put the application it could
probably work that way too it's like and
I feel bad for this so Rachel being
white on the mainland there's a lot of
privileges if you're what white on the
rock you got your ass beating every day
so he didn't reap the benefits of being
a white guy been in Hawaii yeah yeah
you're right but I mean it also depends
it all depends on what he said before
and how it was said there's so much
context right so for example let's say
he's up there he goes hey I represent a
bunch of Asians but don't worry I'm one
of them and I get their struggle if you
said it that way it's like shut the [ __ ]
up dude
but if he's like hey even though I'm
white you know my wife sometimes says
that she reminds me of Asians too and
you know I represent a county that has a
lot of Asians and I care a lot about the
community yeah that's very different
I feel like an extreme connection to it
yeah that's very trapped in a white guy
body yeah yeah so it really depends on
context and how he said it and and you
know sometimes people give bad examples
but i i highly doubt this was like yeah
i know what it's like to be asian
because it because i can kind of wrap my
head around it but i can't because i
have to do it from a personal lens and
i'm not offended
so right from a personal is I'm not
either
cuz it's not that awesome being asian a
plus and your parents tell you you
[ __ ] suck in your dumb I don't know
why people want to have that like my
parents did when I got a seat they're
like finally he's trying thanks dad that
was me and that was my brother there it
is
I think people are just [ __ ] so
sensitive about like what people should
say what they're allowed to say how they
should say it all this [ __ ] have a
critical though cuz they're probably
behind the scenes doing the [ __ ]
worst [ __ ] I've
I know man what's judgmental people are
the ones that are like they see their
flaws and other protection for you
everybody does that [ __ ] I mean we
always like the beat we hate the things
that we hate in ourselves you know so
you don't want to be making those
mistakes or you had made those mistakes
before and you see as somebody else too
pissed you off that one tweet about
Rachel Dolezal there it actually says
Rachel Dolezal gonna have a fit if he
gets away with it she hit her family
with a black dude it was a daddy shed
you know she lied though like
interesting it's not even the same which
would you rather have as a politician
all right one guy is racist as [ __ ] but
he actually gets the job done for you in
the community and you live a better life
because they're effective oh right or
the guy that's nice and and very PC and
and he doesn't make anybody feel bad but
at the same time he's incompetent he
[ __ ] [ __ ] up he over spends does all
kinds of crazy stupid [ __ ] but then the
racist guy is only looking out for the
people he loves though so we're all
[ __ ] it's local local politics not not
not like yeah like not effective in that
and those people need a better
definition of racism if he's only
helping the people it's so extreme yeah
I'll go with what you were trying to say
so I'll go visitors can go but I'll go
with the racist guy who's effective yeah
trying to say like it's like people are
so worried about the wrong [ __ ] you know
to be like let's let's look at what they
actually done as politicians prejudice
[ __ ] he'll be all my people yeah
[Music]